[Music]
we love you make it feel like Christmas
thank you so much fun and you co-wrote
the song right I sent yeah I sent Gwyn a
couple of lines of the song she they
took it and made the song what it is I
just sent her an idea and she tries to
say that I co-wrote it but the lines is
I found forever in that very first kiss
is that about you two
I would like to think so come on man
this is this is romance around here of
course I mean when's your forever oh I
see what you had you had to ask that
didn't you how gorgeous does she look in
that video oh how gorgeous does she look
all the time it's unbelievable right now
wherever she is she looks gorgeous
whatever she's doing well do you guys
have xmas plans together uh yes we do
I'm not sure she normally just tells me
what we're doing so I couldn't tell you
what they are yeah yeah I'm just war
ever she is I'll be there what's just a
word to describe how you're approaching
the voice this season what's on your
mind winning is that all you think about
oh my god it's not a competitive god off
I cheer for all the other coaches all
the other contestants like like he
wasn't interested and now over here I
was younger then when I said that just
like we said a minute jennifer hasn't
had a chance to experience the block
yeah
how competitive is it so far this year
are the knee are there any bets going on
between all you guys I don't want to
take money or anything from these other
three coaches because they're my friends
I'm here to win I came here to win and
you take money from Adam and look Adam
owes me a lot of money here's the worst
at like these little side bets and then
when it happen when it happened when it
goes down
he doesn't remember we didn't shake on
it it's not oh man what about you and
Kelly that's a rivalry like how how
intense is that good I don't take Kelly
seriously you know as a person yes as a
coach sit here and talk about the fact
that I've won the show six times not
last year when I arrived I won I mean we
let her win the first seat I let her win
gracious she was on but well because you
came into the show with a win from the
UK version so keep it about yeah yep
well let me ask you we we spoke to your
contestants and they kind of threw
something out there they said you don't
know how to floss the dance and I was
wondering if you wanted to address that
or maybe show us that you can maybe you
can teach him Jan I don't know if you
want to see Blake throws wigs dancing is
hideous
look Singh the record straight flossing
is an open I know I don't don't fly did
do it once on the show but no it was a
one-time deal I did it for the Blind
Auditions a couple of seasons ago
ratings were through the roof I don't
know if this you're starring in the new
movie cats that cast list is insane have
you talked to anybody else yet how
excited are you or what can you teach
have I spoken to any my character Cassie
not yet I have yet to meet them are
Swift address Elba who took your time I
don't I refuse to accept that somebody
else has that title its movie which yeah
I'm so excited about the cast though
it's a moving in of eggs what is it
gonna what's it gonna be like happy neat
easy I don't even know where to begin
but it'll be something extremely
different
it'll be very different for me because
I've never played a cat before
huh and you have to have an English
accent I know I think memory so I have
to have my you want to try the British
accent all alone in the moonlight
you